يبدو ان السعاده الزوجيه مهمه وضروريه
اكثر مما كنا نتخيل فالامر تجاوز الصحه
النفسيه ووصل الى صحه الجسم وتحديدا القلب
وبحسب صحيفه جيل ميل بريطانيه فان مشكلات
العلاقات الزوجيه يمكن ان تؤدي الى اجهاد
شديد ما يؤثر سلبا في صحه القلب والاصابه
بالم في الصدر ووجدا علماء بجامعهيه لصحه
العامه ان الازواج غير السعداء في
علاقاتهم هم اكثر عرضه بنسبه 50% ادخالهم
الى المستشفى بعد اصابته بنوبه قلبيه
واشار الى انهم كانوا اكثر عرضه بالنسبه
لسبعه 67% للابلاغ عن الام بالصدر في
العام الذي اعجبنا بعض النتائج اظهرت ان
الحياه الشخصيه يمكن ان تؤدي دورا
الرئيسيين في ساعات الناس والاجهاد الذي
يعانيه المرء في الحياه اليوميه مثل
الاجهاد زوجي قد يؤثر في ساعات الشباب بعد
نوبه قلبيه